David we often talk about the bloated US
budget what would you cut from the US
budget if given a choice so this is a
difficult conversation to have because
the reality about the budget is that
everything is a negotiation not all cuts
are created equal not all cuts save
money sometimes you actually have to
spend money in order to save money by
increasing efficiency so I think that
that's important to keep in mind it's
also really important to look at
agencies and see which agencies are
actually doing what they were put in
place to do where is their efficiency
where is their inefficiency what
purposes do different agencies and
departments serve so this is not coming
from some you know small government
libertarian idea of let's start cutting
departments because we just want to make
government small this is the reality
that there's probably a lot of
consolidation and things that can be
moved around but just like to take the
lowest hanging fruit first the military
and Department of Defense obviously are
bloated and need to be cut we don't need
50 bases in Germany to the extent Trump
wants to reduce that I agree with that
the way in which it's done obviously is
the question we have a massive amount
the thing is it's just so easy to say
this it's like okay I'm on the left we
should cut the military we'll still be
safe I think it's more interesting to
look for example at cutting specifically
military contractor spending that's a
much more specific angle where the right
and many of the on the left in in
Congress just are absolutely tied to
these groups that lobby for more
military contractor spending that
specifically needs to be reduced
you can probably consolidate for example
you know does TSA Customs and Border
Patrol people want ice abolished all
together there's probably a big
opportunity there to like dissolve
reformulate consolidate etc that would
represent a cost savings and then
there's a bunch of spent
money to save money sort of
considerations there's a lot of stuff
where we need more money in the short
term like infrastructure upgrading
buildings switching federal buildings to
renewable energy etc etc we're in the
short term we actually have to spend
more over the long term we will save the
problem with these conversations about
what to cut is that once you understand
you you can't how do I want to say this
everything is a negotiation
there's tons of favors and amendments
and this is sort of like how policy is
done right now and to really cut
properly to have a shot at actually
cutting the types of spending that is
the problematic spending you need to
completely change so many aspects of our
political system and there's a lot of
good books written about this and
articles about it but you know me
listing stuff maybe is interesting and I
don't think I'd have anything super
surprising but what we need to actually
change is the way that this system of
cronyism and oh you know wink wink I'll
go for your amendment if you go for mine
and this port
you know everybody's put that the truth
is we talk about pork barrel projects
everybody's poor you know everybody's
pork is someone else's in many cases
community project right so you know I
get you to sign off on rebuilding some
ice rinks in my district and that seems
like pork if you're representing Hawaii
and I'm in Illinois but then you reverse
it and we have very similar situations
looking from Illinois over to Hawaii and
this is really part of the problem and
part of the problem of how budgeting is
done but all of that being said
Department of Defense military
absolutely huge opportunities to cut for
sure no question about it okay make sure
that you don't miss today's bonus show
which will be hosted by producer Pat you
can get instant access by becoming a
member at join pakman.com or a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
will be back on Monday later next week
we will be on a little David Pakman show
vacation we've not had one since the
start of coronavirus because there's
nothing to do and nowhere to go
I will
be doing a little traveling within the
state with a mask and with with
everything rubber gloves the face
shields everything we'll tell you more
about that next week
pad on the bonus show today I'll be back
on Monday